well good evening welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight if you watch this show
from time to time you know that we
really have tried to keep an open mind
about the robert muller russia
investigation that sounds insincere but
it's not it's sincere if American
citizens colluded with a hostile foreign
power to hurt the United States we would
want to know about it we would never
defend disloyal behavior like that no
matter who the president was so for the
last year we have consistently held back
even as ominous signs accumulated we
struggled against calling the Muller
investigation a partisan witch hunt
designed to topple a president we didn't
want to think that it was unfortunate is
getting harder to deny that now as
federal judge TS Ellis put it last week
Muller is seeking only information that
quote would reflect on mr. Trump or lead
to his prosecution or impeachment there
you have it
that's not a law enforcement
investigation he's describing assuming
it ever was that is a hit job on a
democratically elected leader the left
knows this and of course it pleases them
removing Trump from office is the only
principle they recognize but instead of
admitting that they lecture the rest of
us in grave tones about the rule of law
like they really care what the
Constitution says of course they don't
as Pat Buchanan pointed out in a pretty
smart piece over the weekend Muller
doesn't have the power to take Trump out
no independent counsel would the only
institution empowered to prosecute a
president is the Congress the presidency
is a political office voters get to
decide who fills it other elected
officials check the president's power
not unaccountable investigators or rogue
FBI agents not Peter Strock or Lisa
Paige the Congress if the president has
committed a crime the Congress can put
him on trial
that's called impeachment they could do
it tomorrow if they wanted it's in the
Constitution an impeachment and this is
the best part takes place openly in
public the rest of us can watch it and
evaluate it every step of the way there
are no redacted documents or leaked
messages from creepy FBI agents the
whole thing is transparent and that's
how democracies are supposed to operate
openly ironically the one group that
understands this is the Democratic base
kind of amazing but it's true they badly
want to impeach Donald Trump and they
say so they're leaders in the Democratic
Party lie about it and they do it for
the same reason they lie about
everything because all they care about
really is power they don't want to scare
voters before the midterm election so
they don't mention impeachment and
instead they use unelected bureaucrats
with guns to crush the presidency and
the worst part is it's working